Michael Bisping the defending UFC
middleweight champion of the world
joining us right here where they belt in
the other chair to his right good to see
you here on the Rich Eisen show thank
you very much that's a very shiny belt
you have right it is indeed yes the UFC
they they keep it nice and shiny for me
so is that is that a that's a real deal
belt this is whether this isn't my one
you know I mean I tend not to walk
around as I said it was so shiny jewelry
you know I mean there's a word for
things like for somebody that does that
and I won't say it on TV but yeah this
is a this symbolizes a lifetime's hard
work okay and well then congratulations
thanks Matt and we will talk about your
your title fight with George st. Pierre
at UFC 217 in a second but I could not
help but notice you were at Dodger
Stadium last night you were part of the
montage of celebrities that were is that
how many baseball games have you been to
you know I mean to be honest you know
let's let let's be honest here I'm
English so we're not the biggest
baseball fans but I enjoy all sports
obviously and always nice to be the
shock of the atmosphere and the passion
yes yeah I've been to several games you
probably count them on both hands okay
but yeah I mean last night was it was
amazing did you stick for the hole not
all of it not all that I'm training for
a fight as I'm sure as you just
mentioned so you know I'm very tired and
I'm dieting so I stuck around for a
while and then you know I had to get
back and get some sleep okay
did you have a doctor talk I did it no I
did it so I've got a friend over there
he's vegan so he's my nutritionist and
on top of that he's vegan so you can
imagine what a killjoy he's you know not
only easy my nutritionist he's also a
vegan so a hot dog there was no chance
there was no you gotta leave you're not
just respect we have not met sir is that
your you the vegan yes you gotta leave
your vegan nutritionist no I know I
don't
I just sparked five fives with the fresh
sparring partner every round and when I
got there I was starving and I said
listen I don't care I'm gonna games yeah
I'm having a hotdog and he went no
you're not having a hotdog you and I'm
like dude come on I'm on a game with the
world Syria and getting a dog and is
that no no I had broccoli with chicken
to God where he found it from at a
baseball game but with chicken and
broccoli the famed
farmer John's chicken and broccoli yeah
it was so good man
are you an NFL fan or into that yeah
yeah he's got quite a good following
these days in the stage certainly we go
you know we get involved with a Super
Bowl yeah you know somewhat you know
typically more come Busboys if I'm
honest what about your version of
football both yeah you know I'm a much
as United fine I'm once again I mean for
an Englishman because English live and
breathe soccer you know it's a I
appreciate you using the word soccer yes
it's called football I know they kick a
ball with your feet heads football you
guys call it football you hold it in
your hands I just don't get it I think
we claim football Bob soccer yeah well
God sorry I appreciate that but you're
so your man might just you know yeah
yeah yeah but not a die-hard for an
Englishman I'm not considered a real
Englishman because you know first I go
back home to England I get into a cab
first thing he says what Cindy support
mate and then they start talking about
football I'm not a die-hard you know so
talk to me about firing I'll bore you to
death okay so let's talk about fun right
here you recently said that if you're
running the UFC you'd want George st.
Pierre to win why because George is a
huge star and the UFC has a promotion
listen I mean that was tongue in cheek
you know but good for you for picking
that that's you know that's what we do
we mix of course of course I'm rightly
so so he should George is a big star
it's up to me to play the upset he wants
to come back he wants to make history he
wants to win a belt in two divisions
he's our the whole nation of Canada
behind him you know there's a good
storyline there I'm saying if I was the
promoter I'd want George to do it and
then he could take part in some other
super fights but of course I've got to
play the spoiler of course you do and
what's your reaction to all the
back-and-forth that's been going on
between the two you go oh you know what
listen is that your real is that real or
is it just yes no it's real at the time
you know I mean at the end of the day
we're gonna fight you know and when we
fight you know he's vicious we could
dress it up and says Marshall
and all this and that but ultimately we
are going to try and beat each other to
enjoy ever being unconscious or the
referee stopping it so if you can get a
psychological advantage make them doubt
themselves like that that's why I do it
I don't listen you know I don't walk
around my life trying to be a jerk with
people but we're going to fight and he's
gonna try and inflate harmony so if I
can get him to doubt himself if I can
remind him if I can get in his face let
him know that I'm gonna beat him and I'm
fine now he doesn't perform to the best
of his ability then that helps me so it
is real but I respect George George is
an incredible fighter had an amazing
career and I've got my hands full I know
I've got a tough fight next week so I've
prepared accordingly Michael Bisping
here in studio prior to the fight with
George st. Pierre and you can't help but
notice it's been a lot of GSP heavy
promotion yes once again good for you
you try to twist the knife what I'm
trying to do is to but you can okay okay
please please well the thing is this I
mean I haven't been anywhere I've been
here fighting the best guys in the world
like I always do for a very very long
time George has been off hiding in
Canada maybe you know hanging out with
the Mounties or having some maple syrup
or whatever they do with their skiing or
something I'll just be miserable just be
miserable in cold Canada I've been down
there sunbathing and kicking ass the
whole time so they need to remind
everybody that George is coming back
okay I've always been here you were
actually a noise of everybody watching
this like Jesus will he just disappear I
don't think so I mean in you if so how
long were the sunglasses on last night
well it went dark as you know it was the
see someone on Twitter said wait wait
sunglasses at night I said half an hour
ago it was daylight he's an outdoor
stadium so you know you could have
responded sunglasses for everything
buddy stop vegan nutritionist some was
just sitting there I think that's still
so much territory come on it it did look
like the glint of the lights of the
stadium
it's okay if you want to go full awesome
hey why not why not you know I wish I
had those sunglasses right now for the
glint of that felt on the charity
arriving right over there
the Mayweather and McGregor fight did
you watch it of course okay I didn't why
you know I I did but oh yeah yeah did
you think of it a spectacle or something
you thought was the legit what you said
I didn't go into it expecting like a
legit fight I went into that into it
expected fantastic entertainment which I
got I thought Conor McGregor handled
himself really well I thought he
represented our sport well I mean he did
better than what everybody expected you
know III think kudos to Floyd Mayweather
you know he had a perfect game plan he
weathered the storm he made kind of
punch himself out if you will and then
finish him later in the rounds but I
think everyone enjoyed it it was a great
fight it was exciting you know I watched
you with a ton of friends and everyone
was on the edge of the seat we got what
we paid for it was certainly more
enjoyable than the Pacquiao Mayweather
fight so would you ever want to try
something like that of course I'm a
professional fighter that's what I do so
yeah why not
well I mean because folks would say that
why would you perform better in a spot
that McGregor didn't because I ain't
Conor McGregor I'm Michael Bisping and
we have rolled different individuals I
don't wanna gasp I don't get cited in my
face see you said that I didn't yeah
yeah see see I learned the hard way in a
fight you gotta be conditioned when I
was younger I did a kickboxing fight
there was eight rounds that didn't train
for it first four rounds of tries killed
the guy didn't finish him next four
rounds can I say ass I got my ass kicked
so bad for four rounds and it's the
loneliest place in the world is you'd
the fire and the referee no one there
there's no team to hide behind so I
learned the hard way I'm never going to
a fire underprepared
now did you say ass because you thought
I'm American or isn't an arse arse
it is ours I get a lot of I got a lot of
stick of English people you don't have
to translate for me
I believe it or not not to you guys I've
been of an American trying these days so
the English they're deciding me you know
like I haven't northern accent from the
northern of England so the north
northern the north of England
you know a lot of what I said you guys
don't understand so I have to slow it
down and over pronunciate and then
people on Instagram like what is this
accent you know what I mean so we're
yeah there you go
so do you watch Game of Thrones of
course ok so who's your favorite
character okay so outside of the mother
of dragons would you choose
okay I'll be testing my knowledge here
okay hello John Stowe okay you know so
you know something as opposed to John
Snow is all yours what do you mean oh
yeah yeah you know nothing Jon Snow and
I know a lot of things Rich Eisen I know
don't you worry about me buddy
fantastic do you so a couple more
questions please here with Michael
Bisping here on the Rich Eisen show yeah
there was this civil suit that just
announced today not with you there's not
anything you could talk about this I
mean I mean obviously it's a legal
matter and it's very very unfortunate
it's completely unfactual even in the
what has been reported so far what
happened in the gym are some
contradictory yeah some guys claiming
something happened in the gym I don't
really want to give it any extra
attention but of course you know rightly
so this just happened it's frivolous and
you know it's unfactual it's incorrect
but I haven't even heard anything
official yet you know so obviously I
need to speak to a lawyer and find out
what's going on
she's funny know that whatever happened
all these months ago all of a sudden the
week before the biggest fight of my life
hey suing me UFC do you have me 25
fitness you know I think that paints a
picture that does for for Jon Jones do
you think he's ever gonna fight again
I hope so I hope so he's an incredible
fighter one of the most naturally
talented fighters we've ever seen I know
he's fighting the steroid allegation if
you will and apparently Jeff Novitzky he
runs the the drug testing program
apparently there's something too
apparently there is a legitimate the not
a defense and perhaps the legitimate
reason and if that is the case then then
he needs you know
I'm always dubious with things like this
you know I've never taken steroids and
I've never tested positive you know what
I mean you test positive well you know
you ask me there's no smoke without fire
but John Jones is an amazing fire and
I'd love to see him fight again so when
you head to New York Saturday Saturday
morning okay straight out to New York
yeah have you been in Madison Square
Garden I have I have yeah yeah yeah it's
amazing yeah very exciting that's where
I grew up
oh really I mean mom we know watch the
Knicks and Ray it's an incredibly no I
know a magical building yeah it's an
iconic venue yeah can't wait to get
there gonna take in a show like maybe
see Hamill you know I you know like
right now I'm weighing 200 pounds okay
by next Friday I've got to be 185 yeah
so I've got 15 pounds to lose well you
know so I won't be taking in the side I
didn't have a hot dog last night and I
won't be having popcorn and a show and a
glass of wine well this week I was
wondering by the way is it okay for a
Brit to go to Hamilton or is that just
too raw still a little - a little too
soon the guys love to talk about this
don't you believe it or not we pay no
attention it was like 200 years ago
something you guys still love it you
know just like Donald Trump you go
you're gonna list all the things you're
good at
we're amazing we're great we kicked your
ass - and did you horse that's 200 years
ago
you know guys let go we are all one bit
true and in that respect then let me let
me bridge whatever device just be bridge
I don't wear a red coat when you're when
you're done fighting yes when you're
done kicking the arse of George st.
Pierre yes I've got great pizza places
in New York City for you to go to please
that you just looked at that guy right
in the eye yeah yeah you're vegan
nutritionist and say well listen or say
he can kiss my arse
Michael is that Michael Bisping check
him out again UFC middleweight champion
taking on George st. Pierre on a couple
of Saturdays in Madison Square Garden
great to meet you man lajiye thank you
thanks Evan and you got it George st.
Pierre versus this guy Michael Bisping
again check it out that belt that you're
seeing on TV radio audience it is a
beautiful thing it's on the line on
Madison Square Garden in a couple
Saturdays for more Rich Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Rich Eisen show app